suppose you sit in a beer garden
beautiful weather and you have ordered a
beer the beer comes you put it on the
table and then you touch the table and
the table is unstable and the beer is
brought out and you are angry it's a
four leg table the table is completely
stable the problem is the ground on
which the table stands this is not flat
and that's why one leg is above the
ground and then if you put your hands
against the table it goes down and this
is the instability of the table the
normal solution as we take a sheet of
paper for example this paper which is
under our beer glass and put it under
this leg and for a while it looks okay
but after a few minutes we are angry
again because of this paper is
compressed a little bit and unstability
again and we hate that mathematicians
never have unstable tables they know
what to do and what you do is very very
simple turn the table you start moving
the table and try to turn it so that you
have a quarter of a turn and on the way
of your turning there will be a moment
where it's absolutely stable so you just
rotate it like you rotate and like a
rotating a disc yes I rotate the table
like a disc and typically only a few
centimeters are needed and suddenly it's
stable and this is not by chance this
there is a mathematical proof that this
will always happen you're going to have
to give me that right now I give you
that proof now
yes the ground and here this is the
position of the four legs and we
enumerate them this is like one this is
like - this is like three this is like
four and suppose that like one is above
the floor whereas these three are fixed
on the ground now of course if we put
pressure on one then we see the
instability and now we do the following
we measure the height of liquid we
remember we always measure the height of
black van so if we do that in time then
we get associated to time te we
associate height of leg one so at time
zero we get some T equals zero we get
some number say X larger than zero now
this was nothing has happened now we
start moving and we do that obviously in
time and at each time we measure the
height of leg one and we turn it in this
way yeah so we turn it so that we try to
bring like one into the position of leg
two at each time we measure the height
of leg one so this gives the function f
of T yeah for each time T V measure
here's something important we it can
happen that if we fix we always fix two
three and four
this me remember me fix two three and
four and now it could happen that the
height of Lake van is negative yeah
because of this very happen if we have
put now like one into position of like
two
like to to the position of leg three
like three to the position of fall and
like forth at the position where leg
bandwidth but now we remember that we
fix the position of two three and four I
fix them on the ground I keep them on
the ground and since when we did it here
with in this position this was above the
ground and now we force these three to
be on the ground that means this
position has to be under the ground yeah
you see that if you before you have
fixed these three it's above now you
force this to go down and this is
suddenly another ground so at time one
let's suppose we take the time interval
one until the earth is position so at T
equals one this height is negative so
now we draw if I get a new sheet of
paper now we draw this path so this is
time 0 this is time Y here we draw the
height and at time 0 the height was
something positive and at time 1 the
height was negative so this is f of 0
this is f 4 and now at each time T we
get the position of the height and you
see we get a curve I might go even up
and down but in the very end it has to
end here and now comes the famous
theorem of mathematics the mean value
theorem which just says that if you have
a continuous function which is positive
here and negative here there must be a
position
there it is zero it could be multiple
bills it could be you can you can have
fun with it you turn your table further
and there might be a second position
where this table you don't need that but
it's fun to try that out if you have the
be a Gabi and if you do it the next time
in the beer garden you will see easily
fixed the table and you will be pleased
and the beer tastes even better I'll do
it all the time whenever I'm in a beer
garden or even in a restaurant often the
ground is not flat and I sit there with
my friends and they are saying ah let's
put this under I said don't do it I move
it just a little bit and they are always
very surprised and they were not changed
then it's fixed for the whole evening
what if the tables are all lined up or a
special shape or something oh that's
that's of course the mathematics is
always theoretical so if you cannot move
the table you have to use the old
traditional thing with the paper